everlast you're here because you're
celebrating man it's the 30th
anniversary of jump around [ __ ] 30
years old as [ __ ] you don't go to a
sporting event without hearing it you
don't go to a prom without hearing it
you don't go to a wedding without
hearing it the moment i really really
really realized what was going on beyond
all the like we sent the demo out and
four record companies flew out to la the
next day like
that gave me a hint like something's
going on but was when we came to new
york after we assigned with tommy boy
and i was going to a club at the time
called nels it was like oh yeah i've
been there i think it was on 14th yep so
we were on our way there and walking the
nils the record wasn't out yet just
promo like cassettes walking the nails
at least a dozen cars
blaring it as it's going they're going
as we're going i'm like this is crazy so
you knew you had a slapper well i was
like this is crazy but i was like it's
new york you know and this is where the
record company is they're saturated this
company was good at tommy boy saturated
new york streets with all their [ __ ]
so i was like okay that's crazy they're
doing their thing all right we got to
the club nels was on the uh it had it i
don't know if it was on the second floor
or just had a second floor but we were
up on the second floor and i hear at the
time
another long story is this crisscross
record jump yeah that was old they tried
that the guy that ran that record
company we played him our song first and
he tried to he told those kids to make
that record no [ __ ] i don't blame those
kids at all
i mean they were they were children they
were kids yes all right and they were
told to do it yeah
it was a good idea the guy knew it
anyways that record they shoved that out
right before our record like i remember
like the record company calling us in
and being like don't panic but we got to
show you something and
so we get to the club
they start throwing on that
crisscross record
gotta make a mega and then all of a
sudden you hear they need to go
[Music]
and they just
and
just back to back i thought the floor
was gonna fall out of nails like it was
i
i thought the building was in danger
like all of us were like what the
because the floor was doing this
and i was like oh my god this is going
to be a hit record